das könnte ein durchbruch für die
behandlung von coop 19 sein ein neues
medikament scheint tatsächlich zu helfen
und könnte jetzt erstmals in deutschland
an einem schwer kranken patienten
getestet werden fälle aus china und den
usa bei denen der wirkstoff schon zum
einsatz kam und erfolgreich war geben
hoffnung dort das mittel ist in
deutschland noch gar nicht zugelassen
und darf eigentlich noch niemandem
verabreicht werden aber es gibt einen
silberstreif am horizont zum science
fiction hier gibt es täglich spannende
science videos abonniert den kanal und
aktiviert die glocke nur dann verpasst
er nichts los geht's herzlich willkommen
in weilheim musste ein 80-jähriger
corona patient intensivmedizinisch
versorgt werden weil er in einem
kritischen zustand war
er musste sogar beatmet werden und die
ärzte hatten sorge dass es vielleicht zu
einem lungen versagen kommen könnte der
mann war mit grippeähnlichen symptomen
eingeliefert worden und wurde dann
positiv auf das corona virus getestet
weil sich sein zustand so sehr
verschlechtert hatte wurde ihm vor ein
paar tagen ein medikament gegeben das
eigentlich für die behandlung von hiv
zugelassen ist das hat zumindest etwas
geholfen und ihn stabilisiert jetzt gibt
es großartige neuigkeiten für den
schwerkranken patienten und tausende
andere die infiziert sind ein neues
medikament mit dem namen mdv gibt
endlich hoffnung das weilheimer medizin
team hat das mittel bereits angefordert
nachdem es einen tipp von der uniklinik
düsseldorf bekommen hatte
mit dem die weilheimer fachleute in
engem kontakt stehen
bei dem medikament handelt es sich um
einen us präparat das eigentlich bei der
behandlung von ebola zum einsatz kommen
soll
das problem ist aber dass das präparat
in deutschland noch gar nicht zugelassen
ist es befindet sich in studien in den
usa und in china noch in der testphase
da das aber ein absoluter sonderfall in
einer ausnahmesituation ist hat die
regierung von oberbayern eine
einfuhrgenehmigung erteilt und eine
sondererlaubnis aus den usa zur
personenbezogenen nutzung eingeholt wenn
das revier medikament in bayern
eintrifft könnte es am klinikum weilheim
deutschlandweit das erste mal bei einem
infizierten eingesetzt werden der
wirkstoff endet den rna bausteinen die
rna viren
saas und mehr stoff zur vervielfältigung
des erbgutes brauchen wenn es von den
viralen oberflächen enzymen in die viren
rna also dem träger der erbinformationen
eingebaut wird führt das dazu dass sich
das virus nicht mehr vermehren kann in
amerika und in china gab es bereits
corona fälle die ebenfalls nach einer
sondergenehmigung damit behandelt wurden
und das mit erfolg schon nach der ersten
verabreichung sollen sich die symptome
der korona patienten verbessert haben
ob es das virus aber wirklich
langfristig stoppen kann ist noch nicht
sicher
anthony fauci der direktor des national
institute of allergy and infectious
diseases sagt zitat obwohl rem diese wir
bereits einigen patienten mit 19
verabreicht worden ist haben wir bisher
nicht genügend verlässliche daten um zu
wissen ob es wirklich den verlauf
beeinflusst zum glück laufen aber schon
klinische phase 3 studien mit dem mittel
im medical center der university of
nebraska in oma wird der wirkstoff
gerade an cupid 19 patienten mit
lungenentzündung getestet dabei erhalten
sie am ersten tag der behandlung 200
milligramm intravenös und danach jeweils
100 milligramm täglich gleichzeitig
starten auch in asien zwei weitere
studien mit insgesamt 1019 patienten die
eine ähnliche dosierung bekommt dabei
muss jetzt getestet werden ob der
wirkstoff bei schweren und auch mittel
schweren verläufen wirkt und wie lange
die behandlung durchgeführt werden muss
nur fünf oder sogar zehn tage lang dafür
wurden die patientinnen in zwei gruppen
geteilt eine gruppe besteht aus 400
erkrankten mit schwerem verlauf wie das
mittel nach dem zufallsprinzip entweder
fünf oder zehn tage bekommt die andere
gruppe von 600 erkranken mit schwächeren
form wird entweder fünf oder zehn tage
lang behandelt oder erhält therapien die
bereits für andere corona virusstämme
verwendet werden so soll sichergestellt
werden dass die behandlung mit rem diese
wir eine deutliche verbesserung im
vergleich zum einsatz andere antiviren
mittel bringt oder eben nicht das nennt
man eine randomisierte
plazebokontrollierte studie die für
anthony fauci
der goldstandard ist um zu testen ob
eine experimentelle therapie dem
patienten hilft solche klinische phase 3
studien mit einer größeren anzahl von
testpersonen sollen beweisen dass ein
arzneimittel sowohl sich als auch
in der regel folgt danach die endgültige
behörde die zulassung aber noch steht
nicht fest ob der patient aus weilheim
mit rem die serie behandelt wird sollte
er weiterhin stabil bleiben könnte ja
auch mit herkömmlichen mitteln behandelt
werden und jetzt meldet aktuell der
spiegel dass das medikament in
deutschland getestet wird im april soll
es in der münchner klinik schwabing im
rahmen einer studie des herstellers
eingesetzt werden und auch die
universitätskliniken hamburg und
düsseldorf sollen dabei sein es bleibt
also spannend aber wenn reservierte sich
tatsächlich gegen saas kopf zwei bewährt
kann es zwar die ausbreitung des corona
virus nicht stoppen aber es könnte viele
viele todesfälle durch gewinnt 19
verhindern und das alleine wäre ein
wahnsinns durchbruch hier geht es weiter
mit unserer playlist zum corona virus da
kann man sehr gut nachvollziehen wie
sich das virus langsam verbreitet hat
und es dann zur pandemie kam also
anklicken anschauen und abonnieren
bis dann dran